Y
HOT SEAT FEATURING DEMOCRATIC
RICHARD FOWLER.
WE BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
A BOMBSHELL NEW REPORT FROM THE
WALL STREET JOURNAL HAS NOW
EXPOSED A BLATANT DUAL SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE AT JOE BIDEN'S
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
TONIGHT WE ARE LEARNING THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT REJECTED A
FEDERAL SEARCH FOR TOP SECRET
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS HOUSED AT
JOE BIDEN'S MANY PROPERTIES.
THEY CALLED OFF THE FBI.
NO RAID FOR JOEY.
JOE BIDEN GETS DIFFERENT
TREATMENT THAN TRUMP.
INSTEAD, THEY OUTSOURCED THE
SEARCH TO BIDEN'S OWN PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS AND BIDEN STAFFERS,
INCLUDING MANY WITHOUT ANY
SECURITY CLEARANCE AT ALL
WHATSOEVER.
NOW, IN THE CASE OF THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY, WELL, THEY CAN NOW BE
WITNESSING IN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
ACCORDING TO JONATHAN TURLEY,
QUOTE, THE USE OF PRIVATE
COUNSEL WITHOUT CLEARANCES
FOLLOWING THE FIRST DISCOVERY
COULD ITSELF BE VIEWED AS
RECKLESS AND GROSS MISHANDLING.
BUT AT THIS POINT, BIDEN'S DOJ
DOESN'T REALLY SEEM TO CARE
BECAUSE, QUOTE, MR. BIDEN'S
ATTORNEYS HAD QUICKLY TURNED
OVER A FIRST BATCH.
THEY WERE COOPERATING.
RIGHT.
THEY QUICKLY TURNED OVER A FIRST
BATCH.
SIX YEARS AFTER THE DOCUMENTS
WERE TAKEN FROM THEIR RIGHTFUL
HOME.
OF COURSE, THE SAME LENIENCY WAS
NEVER IN THE CARDS FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
REMEMBER, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WAS COOPERATING WITH FEDERAL
OFFICIALS INQUIRING ABOUT
DOCUMENTS POTENTIALLY AT MAR
A-LAGO.
HE INVITED THEM TO HIS HOME.
HE ALLOWED UNFETTERED ACCESS TO
THE DOCUMENTS.
FBI AGENTS ACTUALLY WERE FREE
AND CLEAR AND WENT IN THE ROOM
WHERE THE DOCUMENTS EVENTUALLY
WERE FOUND, AND THEY NEVER ASKED
FOR THEM, EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
THERE.
TRUMP THEN SECURED THE DOCUMENTS
WITH A PADLOCK IN THAT ROOM AT
THEIR REQUEST.
AND YET IN THE EARLY MORNING
HOURS OF AUGUST 8TH, A TACTICAL
TEAM FROM THE FBI RAID MAR
A-LAGO, GUNS DRAWN AS THEY
SEARCHED FOR CLOSETS.
THEY TOOK WHATEVER THEY WANTED
BY FORCE.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE
PRESIDENT'S PASSPORT.
BY THE WAY, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, MERRITT GARLAND, THE
FBI DIRECTOR WRAY, BRAGGED ABOUT
SIGNING OFF ON THIS RAID.
THEY WERE UNWILLING TO DO THE
SAME FOR JOE BIDEN.
WHY DIDN'T THEY TELL US WHEN
THEY KNEW SIX DAYS BEFORE THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
APPARENTLY THEY WANT YOU AND ALL
OF US TO JUST TRUST THAT JOE
BIDEN AND HIS ATTORNEYS AND HIS
AIDES ARE GOING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
BUT JOE BIDEN ALMOST NEVER DOES
THE RIGHT THING.
HE IS A NOTORIOUS LIAR WITH VERY
FEW PRINCIPLES OR MORALS.
HE WON'T EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE HIS
OWN 4-YEAR-OLD GRAND DAUGHTER OR
GRANT HER SECRET SERVICE
PROTECTION.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO TAKE HIS WORD
FOR IT IN THIS DOCUMENT
INVESTIGATION?
NOW REMEMBER, IT IS NOW WELL
ESTABLISHED THAT JOE BIDEN, AS
VICE PRESIDENT, MET WITH AT
LEAST 14 OF HUNTER BIDEN'S
SKETCHY FOREIGN BUSINESS
PARTNERS.
HE THEN FLAT OUT LIED REPEATEDLY
ABOUT THOSE MEETINGS, DENIED ANY
KNOWLEDGE OF EVER EVEN SPEAKING
TO HIS SON ABOUT HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS VENTURES.
NOW, OF COURSE, JOE BIDEN WAS
THE CENTER PIECE OF THOSE
INTERESTS, AS HUNTER ADMITTED IN
AN INTERVIEW ON ABC.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN THE LIST YOU GAVE ME OF
THE REASONS WHY YOU'RE ON THERE,
YOU DID NOT LIST THE FACT THAT
YOU WERE THE SON OF THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> OF COURSE, NO.
>> WHAT ROLE DO YOU THINK THAT
PLAYED?
>> I THINK IT IS IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ME TO BE ON ANY OF THE BOARDS I
MENTIONED WITHOUT SAYING I'M THE
SON OF THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> IF YOUR NAME WASN'T BIDEN, DO
YOU THINK YOU WOULD HAVE ASKED
TO BE ON THE BOARD?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
PROBABLY NOT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
IN MY LIFE THAT IF MY LAST NAME
WASN'T BIDEN.
>> Sean: HE ADMITTED HE HAD NO
EXPERIENCE AT OIL OR GAS OR
ENERGY OR UKRAINE OR THE ENERGY
SECTOR AT ALL OR SOPHISTICATED
INVESTING.
ABSOLUTELY NO EXPERIENCE.
ZERO EXPERIENCE.
HUNTER WAS SELLING ACCESS TO HIS
DAD.
THAT'S CALLED INFLUENCE
PEDDLING.
IT HAS A REAL NAME.
IN 2017 WHEN HUNTER WAS STILL
RAKING IN MONEY FROM MANY OF
THESE SKETCHY FOREIGN BUSINESS
PARTNERS, A DOCUMENT OBTAINED BY
MIRANDA DIVINE AND THE DAILY
CALLER SHOWS JOE BIDEN WAS
PURPORTEDLY COLLECTING $50,000
IN RENT PER MONTH AT HIS
DELAWARE HOME FROM HIS OWN SON.
WHY?
NOW, IT'S NOT PALM BEACH AND
IT'S NOT MALIBU, CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS TRUE AND HUNTER WAS
ACTUALLY PAYING POPS 50 GRAND A
MONTH TO RENT A ROOM IN
DELAWARE, THEN I THINK WE ALL
KNOW HOW THE BIG GUY WAS TAKING
HIS CUT.
GET THIS.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM JOHN
SOLOMON, HUNTER AND AT LEAST ONE
OF HIS BUSINESS ASSOCIATES, THEY
DISCUSSED JOE BIDEN'S EARNINGS
POTENTIAL AND WEALTH CREATION IN
AN E-MAIL CHAIN TITLED JRB
FUTURE.
JR BE,  -- THE PLANS HEAVILY
INVOLVED THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF
CHINA.
NOT ONLY DID CHINA CONTRIBUTE
TENS AND TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA AFTER THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE BIDEN
CENTER, $67 MILLION IN TOTAL FOR
THE UNIVERSITY, $47.7 MILLION
ONCE JOE BIDEN WAS OUT OF
OFFICE.
BUT HUNTER ALSO SCORED A
LUCRATIVE DEAL WITH A CHINESE
ENERGY FIRM, AND THAT INCLUDED
THAT $5 MILLION INTEREST-FREE
FORGIVABLE LOAN.
THIS WAS IN ADDITION TO THE
$100,000 SHOPPING SPREE WITH A
CHINESE NATIONAL.
BY THE WAY, WE CAN'T FORGET THE
MULTIBILLION DOLLAR SWEETHEART
DEAL WITH THE BANK OF CHINA, NO
EXPLANATION WHY THEY DIDN'T GO
TO GOLDMAN SACHS, JP MORGAN,
DEUTSCHE BANK OR MAYBE A REAL
FIRM.
SO, YEAH, TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS
LYING AROUND AT THE U PENN
CENTER AND IN JOE'S GARAGE AND
IN HIS LIBRARY AND IN HIS OTHER
HOUSE.
THAT'S DEEPLY CONCERNING.
BUT ACCORDING TO MANY IN THE
MOB, THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS, NO
BIG DEAL AT ALL.
WE JUST HAVE TO TRUST JOE BIDEN.
THEY ONLY HAVE ONE TRUE BOOGIE
MAN IN ALL OF THIS AND HIS NAME
WHEN ALL ELSE FAILS AND THE DOG
BITES AND THE BEE STINKS AND
YOU'RE FEELING SAD, YOU GOT TO
BLAME DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
NEEDS TO DO ITS RISK AND DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT ABOUT HOW DONALD
TRUMP STARTED RECKLESS HANDLING
OF THESE DOCUMENTS MIGHT HAVE
HARMED OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THEY FIND THE DOCUMENTS, THEY
REPORTED THEM IMMEDIATELY.
ANYBODY WHO SAYS IT'S A
DIFFERENT SITUATION IS A
POLITICAL HACK.
>> IF THE TRUMP PEOPLE
REPRESENTED THAT THEY PROVIDED
ALL THE CLASSIFIED OR NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION AND DIDN'T,
THAT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
AS FAR AS WE CAN TELL IT WAS
INADVERTENT THAT THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE IN THESE LOCATIONS.
WHEN THEY WERE DISCOVERED THEY
WERE IMMEDIATELY PROVIDED TO THE
ARCHIVES OR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THERE WAS NO EFFORT TO HOLD ON
TO THEM, NO EFFORT TO CONCEAL
THEM.
>> THIS WAS NOT A MISTAKE THAT
THESE DOCUMENTS LANDED AT MAR
A-LAGO.
THIS IS WHAT HE INTENDED.
IT SHOWS THEY WANT TO GET THESE
DOCUMENTS BACK AND EVERY SECOND
THEY ARE AT THE BEACH HOUSE IN
THE POSSESSION OF DON'TED A
TRUMP, THAT IS A RISK TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> HE SHOULD HAVE SAID, LOOK, I
KNOW I LOOK HYPOCRITICAL IN THAT
TAPE.
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> Sean: ALL THOSE PEOPLE ARE
ALL POLITICAL HACKS.
LUCKILY, WE HAVE AN HONEST PRESS
SECRETARY WITH A VERY SOLID
GRASP OF THE FACTS WHO'S
COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY.
ONLY KIDDING.
OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS, SHE HAS
SADLY EMBARRASSED HERSELF OVER
AND OVER AS SHE HAS ATTEMPTED
AGAIN AND AGAIN TO STONEWALL THE
PRESS AND HAS TOLD THEM, LET'S
JUST CALL THEM UNTRUTHS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT -- SHARE
WITH YOU WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
TO ALL OF YOU, RIGHT, WHICH IS
HE WAS SURPRISED BY THIS.
HE DEFINITELY TRULY RESPECTS THE
PROCESS HERE.
AND ALSO WHEN IT COMES TO
CLASSIFIED, HE TAKES CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS VERY SERIOUSLY.
THAT SEARCH WAS COMPLETED LAST
NIGHT AND NOW THIS IS IN THE
HANDS OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
IT HAS BEEN COMPLETED, YES.
WHEN THEY COMPLETED THE SEARCH
WITH DOCUMENTS BEING FOUND LAST
NIGHT.
I HAVE ANSWERED YOUR QUESTIONS
ALMOST EVERY DAY ON THIS ISSUE.
AGAIN, ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU
MAY HAVE, ANYTHING THAT'S
RELATED TO THE REVIEW, I WOULD
REFER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
YOU'VE ASKED ME THIS 100 TIMES,
200 TIMES, IF YOU WISH.
I'M GOING TO KEEP SAYING THE
SAME THING.
>> ARE YOU UPSET THAT YOU CAME
UP TO THIS PODIUM FRIDAY WITH
INCOMPLETE AND INACCURATE
INFORMATION?
AND ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT IT
AFFECTS YOUR CREDIBILITY UP
HERE?
>> WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO NOT
POLITICALLY INTERFERE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT WE CONTINUE TO BE
CONSISTENT OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
THAT IS CONTINUE TO REFER YOU
ALL WHEN IT COMES TO ON GOING
PROCESS, AND I'LL JUST LEAVE IT
THERE.
>> Sean: SO OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HEAR THE TRUTH FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN ANY WA